[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
few titles command the respect and
fandom that the Assassin's Creed series
has garnered and today we get to talk
about Assassin's Creed Valhalla with its
creative director ashraf Ismail who's
joining us from Montreal Canada
Bienvenue - inside Xbox hey pleasure to
be here I'm so glad that you're here
because I'm a huge fan of the series
after seeing the video that we just saw
I had literally hundreds of questions to
ask you but before we get into Valhalla
itself did I just see new Assassin's
Creed game play for the first time yeah
absolutely that was directly from the
game and all its viking-age glory let's
talk about the Viking Age because
Assassin's Creed Odyssey Assassin's
Creed origins these took place in
antiquity they were sun-drenched
Mediterranean places and this looks very
different different time different place
so what do you have for us with the
Viking Age yeah so the the Viking Age
it's named after one of history's most
notorious warrior cultures and this time
period is highlighted by the invasion of
England by this very large hungry Viking
horde and at the time England was a Dark
Age tangle of broken warring kingdoms so
this was an absolutely brutal pivotal
moment in history that gave us the birth
of the England we know today so players
can expect to fully live the Viking
fantasy in a meticulously crafted
journey in an assassin's creed world all
right so let's let's get a little bit
bored into this there was a lot to take
in and that clip that we saw I saw
Viking longships I saw some very mean
looking axes previously we saw like
hidden blade so let's talk about some of
the key new features that you're
bringing to the table with Assassin's
Creed Valhalla
yeah so our hero a war is a Viking
Raider who's going to leave the snowy
mountains of Norway for the lush rolling
hills of England propelled by the goal
of settling their people and growing
thriving settlement now England at this
time is a hostile
place so to succeed the players will go
raiding using their longships and
raiding party
they'll assault giant fortifications and
epic battles they'll have to gain
alliances with kings and legendary
Vikings and they'll be faced with some
very harsh choices as the leader of a
community along with that where we've
reinvented combat to be visceral brutal
tons of enemy variety dual wielding
weapons we have a new fresh take on
player progression gear and weapon
systems
we're effectively pushing every single
envelope to deliver this incredible
Viking fantasy all this is just music to
my ears thank you so much so this whole
show we've been talking about the Xbox
series X we're talking about next-gen so
as a creative director someone creating
a huge epic game how do you take
advantage of this new hardware
well Assassin's Creed has always been
committed to new technologies in order
to push the most immersive experiences
we possibly can and so to have something
like incredibly fast loading times means
that we can remove some of that friction
from the immersion and create a game
that's much more immersive Norway and
Dark Ages England are breathtaking
living worlds so to be able to push them
further to their incredible potential
this is really wonderful for us it's
wonderful for our players and
additionally I'm very happy to confirm
that we are also offering smart delivery
which allows you to purchase the game
once and play it on your Xbox one and
the Xbox Series X that is great news I
think for all the Assassin's fans out
there they'll be able to enjoy it on the
hardware they have now maybe on the
hardware that they are looking forward
to getting later this year thank you so
much
ash wrap this melt for joining us and
for sharing the very first details on
Assassin's Creed Valhalla I cannot wait
to see more
absolutely it's my pleasure
[Music]
we have seen so many great games today
showcasing gameplay for Xbox series X so
let's go to Malik right now with Robert
carp from Codemasters to talk dirt five
all right everyone just a few minutes
ago you saw the reveal trailer of dirt 5
and it will